I don't think most people realize how
deeply engraved the capitalist mentality
is but here's something to ponder AI is
in the news a lot right now as AI
programs are showing that they can
generate art they can generate written
works things that require creativity
things that for a long time we assumed
only humans would be able to do so now
along with all the jobs of course have
been loss of automation you know more
physically intensive labor intensive
jobs people are wondering what do we do
about the jobs that are lost what what
what we do what do we do when all the
jobs can be done by robots
and the worries clearly we won't have
jobs
we won't be able to pay our our bills
our rent we won't have food we won't
have homes
why isn't the question
if all the jobs can be done by robots
why are we even requiring people to work
if there's no need for human labor why
would you still require it
and have people be left to die if they
don't do it